remember remember that sammy
was asking him about the things in the
oven and asking if there was recording
devices in the oven
well she didn't like she didn't like
baked alaska's answer she didn't like
her dad's answer
so now she's gonna babble to this clerk
at the gas station about how she thinks
there's recording devices
in the oven of her dad's efficiency
i consider you the only real reporter
out on the field somebody uh
enter a ban over on periscope says was
is that birdie is she back okay guess
not no this is sammy man sammy
the rest sit in offices and read
corporate agendas
keep traveling around and don't kidding
what is happening in the u.s
the only tragedy is it's not safe for
our kids to see
thank you very much i will continue to
do that what's up the other way
this is what he's buying isn't it green
just don't show my credit card we don't
want people fine
okay okay i just want to show you notice
how what photoshop can do
sammy baked got caught with his hand in
the cookie jar
and the cookies are much younger better
looking girls
i don't care before he tosses you ass
aside like all the other
crazy chicks it's all on stream
go and watch if you can handle it
i don't need receipts thanks so much
ready yeah yeah you need anything
amanda tyler is her other personality
the splitting personality being brought
on by her father
amanda
[Music]
[ __ ] her now it makes sense
he did it for the booty i don't know if
he still is or not
but think about it yeah that's how
she initially got control of him that
makes sense this guy right here
we're just getting some waters do you
guys have uh sparkling water if you have
alcohol or not in liquid
water yeah right there
all right thank you
doing it if they were open they're shut
down yeah
um
i'm looking for the part there is a part
where she's literally showing the clerk
her [ __ ] did they go back in maybe
there was a point where she was
literally showing the clerk asking him
hey look at these
are these wires for a recording device
and like even the clerk was like
okay this is kind of weird um so anyway
the party's just getting started guys
let's go back to the old d live replay
so we can go back fast forward a little
bit we're going back to meet up with dad
i think he did mr sam he was nice to me
i could see in his eyes i know my dad he
sweet dealer where's the weed dealer uh
he was right over there
his name's joe the guy at the store what
are you doing real quick is the story of
your life
truman should story how about let's just
go in and i'll give him some money
baby pigs basically that's right
and it's like wow well okay um
what i was gonna say though let's take a
trip to flavor town
baby i see that yeah hey
i don't really look that bad dude no you
look good
all right i'm turning the tts off guys
um so
we're going to go talk to your dad
you're ready
all right get ready for you
get ready if you thought dad was awesome
the first time
well get ready kids strap in because
it's going to get real here in a second
the lights
yeah that's a normal light every corner
why are you paranoid about the light
i'm not paranoid i'm just annoyed
i'm just aware
[Music]
dad
that is ejaculating into the oven
somebody said in the chat
[Music]
by the way i'll say this one person i
didn't notice in that chat all night
long was [ __ ] ethan ralph i was there
i was watching most of the night and
even when i checked back later and i
looked at the chat i still see
i still seen ralph reporting in from his
[ __ ] ralph retort
account i was like god damn dude
literally
everyone everyone on d live was in this
chat room last night everyone and
there were a lot of check marks hanging
out on this stream on t-lock last night
it was really funny are you asleep
dad
all grown up have you ever seen that
movie
oh is that too bright why are you
showing me i'm trying to show mean girls
that's me get ready get ready
[Music]
by the way i've lived in these things
before and
they're all right they're all right like
trust me i've lived in like like when i
when i met royce
when i first moved to miami i lived in
an efficiency
and um you know when you're like 24
you know and you're out like working in
clubs and then sleeping all day you
don't really need a huge house you know
so
i had an efficiency and they're fine if
you're by yourself
if you live by yourself an efficiency
can have any everything you need but
when you have like
you can't take anybody in if you live in
an efficiency there is no guest
there's no there's no guest space like i
i don't have a huge apartment now but i
have a two bedroom
and this studio is the second bedroom if
somebody had to visit
i have a living room i have uh a second
bedroom that's a studio with a
like there's places you could crash if
you were staying here but like
you can't do that in an efficiency
it's it's um big says i had an
efficiency in new york i loved it
yeah if it's like literally if all you
need is a place to shower sleep and [ __ ]
and change your clothes and go back to
work or go out whatever you're doing
that's fine for a young person
efficiencies are dope
but if you have somebody that's like hey
dad i'm stuck i need a place to live
you're [ __ ] if you live in an
efficiency
get ready the socks are filthy
everything is so
awful maybe you could place a
i painted it actually you're ready
[Music]
i'm
you sleep in that corner how can you fit
there
yes guys she sleeps in that corner
like a dog
it's hard to explain yeah and it was
hard for people to take me seriously
because i really think i'm
[ __ ] nuts but if it happened to you
you would understand
[Laughter]
okay this i swear to god this week
by the way that noise the fall out of
the bed
every there's there was nothing about
that
that wasn't perfect there was nothing
about that that wasn't weird
she woke up and he rolled over and he
fell off the bed
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] oh it's the greatest thing ever
dude i couldn't by the way this was at
like 4 30 in the morning this is when it
was
really late that they went back there
i i was i was [ __ ]
dying at that wow yeah
of course i'm gonna play it again what
are you nuts
i didn't do that
no i know i actually do are you okay
[Music]
yeah we got yeah we got it before too we
got yeah we got fireball and vodka
yeah you want some um
[Music]
yeah he wanted weed not booze exactly
yes for weed but
um these are lazy people that don't do
what they're asked look at this
here's some vodka for you it leaves it
on the
oh wow look alaskan nobody's drinking
any of these that's your you gotta take
no leave it because it's the only way
you're like yeah uh but don't these look
weird why do they make them like that
anyway i don't know why he hasn't
drinking any of that
sorry you gotta drop them
look at this whoa all these green who
brings these
um daddy of these oh yeah yeah yeah we
got to show the best
you got to take no you got to show the
best yeah
but don't these look weird why do they
make them like that
anyway i don't know why he hasn't
drinking any of that
sorry daddy
that's the stains they were talking
about by the way i don't
i don't think they're pissed stains they
could be but because they're on the
floor
like that that indicates more of
a uh eating in bed a lack of furniture
that's probably a spilled drink or so
that's like sleeping on the floor
leaving a drink on the floor and then
knocking the drink over and it going
everywhere like
if it was pissed it'd be up here and it
would be in the like that looks like
like just dumped over something like
probably beer stains
um something like that but yeah it's
just spilled but it's just gross in
general
they bring in so many bags of apples and
onions
apples onions and potatoes yummy what is
look at this whoa all these greens who
brings these
um dad who brings his face
mumbling to himself they brought these i
put them up here because i don't like
orange
hmm
[Music]
yeah let's make him a drink by the way
you're not supposed to serve alcohol to
people
in that kind of shape that's not a good
thing if you woke somebody up from being
passed out drunk and they're like
my um just give me a drink
i was i knew i knew samia's drink man
this is amazing you don't serve somebody
that's this drunk
do you want a beer or no or a mixed face
that's what i'm talking about
this is what photoshop let's make your
dad color
what good they have give me a beer
barrier
[Music]
yes sir yeah
all right
yeah black love it yeah it was funny we
came in here
and you just rolled right off the bed
it was real that was really funny
[Music]
would not come open on this thing and i
was like
they do not these manufacturers do not
want
let's open this yeah that was good i'm
glad you know what's funny
it was really you know when you said it
sammy originally in the car when you
said it
bro it was [ __ ] funny and then i was
like man
i hope you relay that amusing anecdote
later when we get back to your dad's
house
like because the first time you said it
again it was really funny
and i was like dude it's too bad your
dad wasn't here
to hear that epic line but you actually
had the foresight
to say you know what i gotta tell dad
about this you know
she is sammy's literally paulie walnuts
she's she's doing the paulie walnuts
thing when remember when he was like uh
he said something about a [ __ ] and he
goes yeah i got it from your mother
when i went to france she was working
the bon-bon concession at the eiffel
tower and then he turns immediately and
goes
hey so you hear what i said to him i
says
yeah i got it from your mother she was
working the bon-bon concession at the
eiffel tower
she's literally paulie walnuts
she's being paulie walnuts right now
that's hard as [ __ ] i was trying to tell
him what a cool guy you were i'm like
let's just go try to talk to him maybe
he'll wake up
uh anyway i have some money for me
he's definitely a cool guy
that's a cool guy you know what's cool
you know what's cool man it's cool
living in an efficiency
and having your your [ __ ] adult age
daughter sleeping in a pile of clothes
in the corner
and her and working at sizzler and her
offering you weed money
bro you're so cool you're so cool you
know this guy is
he's actually ricky bobby's dad yeah
this guy is gary cole
in talladega nights which kind of
chase how about uh pale ale
oh no there's there's a reason no one's
drunk in those
oh there's a oh natty light how about
that what's that
is that green yeah
so you won't drink the pale ale or the
alaskans
but you'll drink the natty ice god these
people are trash people
are you ever gonna clean that pan what
is that
maybe maybe you should clean it what did
you do to this
i think you should clean it sammy
just let that sit i want i want to sit
here for a moment i really want to
i really want you guys to really like to
drink that in
i want you to really
oh isn't that great i think
exactly yeah i think i have to work
another day well tomorrow
after work you can come do some dishes
yeah gotta have the women do the dishes
you know the men got a
party
no i made dinner yeah no it looked good
looked like you guys had a really nice
thanksgiving dinner uh yeah thanks to me
rearranging it because it was just like
all a bunch of like
the orange uh
hey i found another one whoa black
another black velvet she found another
one
now i look like an alcoholic do you want
this too dad
god forbid
[Laughter]
oh you're funny
can we get that can somebody get that
for me as a soundtrap
can someone please get me that
i need a nice clean i need a nice clean
sound drop of sammy's dad laughing i
love that
yeah that's easy
[Laughter]
carrying two or two of those around
oh no don't tell me this got taken down
no no
please don't tell me this got taken down
no it didn't okay good good good good
good good
what's gonna say because this is good so
where are you from wow
irish and cherokee
that's awesome yeah yeah yeah that's
that's the problem
right yeah it's in the blood yeah
so i didn't even get to go through i i
was sure
oh that's a great picture dude send me
that one i like that one
okay i will please
wow you take good candids and you yeah
sammy said
you or sammy always talks very highly of
you says you're a great dad and
he's laying on the floor sometimes he
went better
yeah she's better yes she does i am i'm
i'm i did the best i [ __ ] could
yeah she's a she's a great girl work
look good sizzler yeah no
[ __ ] good i have to answer i could
actually play guitar and sing
really yeah if i get up here
yeah bust out the guitar can he play no
no
my favorite part about that is that he
said if i get up i like that he didn't
commit
that's you know what i like about
sammy's dad is he he under promises and
he over delivers
you know what i mean he didn't say when
i get up he didn't say he said if i get
up
if i can get up i'll i'll i'll belt out
a [ __ ] tune for you
i don't know so can i
i'll do a second that'd be great yeah if
i can get up
[Laughter]
do you need me to help you get up no no
no no no no
you just need some time no i don't know
yeah yeah yeah
that's a guy you should have given natty
ice and vodka to so bad
wow look how bad this made me look
okay i'm not i'm not he's bad and then
and then
i got you bro
oh yeah now i'm just chilling usually
it's
the cops yikes
i'm just saying seeing the cops they're
telling me
that's good um oh tyler it's not funny
no
i have no idea who she is uh victor rand
it's it's nightwave radio same
everywhere no he doesn't have a clue
okay no these are terms
not ever do you see this ever
[Music]
remember yeah no it's weird because it
won't connect my
like chat stuff i have to like restart
the stream and i'm not going to do that
okay okay okay okay outside of my order
okay okay
okay i i saw her one time
and mind you get this yeah
she had the hardest body that he ever
saw
on girl but she took off her
after about a half hour after i was
walking
was she
her hair looks like yours really no no
no no no doesn't
her hair look like her hair yeah
she's she's on serious drugs and she's
no no
no no she's real beautiful wow
this guy's living the dream it's all
real
the point is yes
[Music]
she [ __ ] had no hair it was like
she had like a weave on she looked like
you
like me like a man yeah see
that's crazy because everyone thought
that sammy was
making her up but you just confirmed
it's all real
it's written oh yeah she's real amanda
yeah
no amanda is real yeah okay no no amanda
is real
yeah whoa bombshell she did get a breast
implant
and that's why he said she has nice
boobs yeah yeah she didn't used to have
nice foods but uh
not that she didn't use that nice
because she used to look a lot different
yeah when we were teenagers i want to
see this amanda taylor's tits
you saw amanda
[Laughter]
she's your daughter's age sir
she's smoking smoking she's smoking
gotcha she's smoking off
but but the point is when she took off
yeah it was like her wig what was going
on in flagstaff gotcha
when the wig came up here yeah [ __ ]
killed my arm
two or three fingers going down yeah you
just killed my heart
how about this
damn
uh
i'm noticing a
i'm noticing a distinct
lack of
boundaries here
right am i the only one who's
am i the only one who's like who thinks
there might be you know what i mean like
there's just some weird [ __ ] that maybe
you don't
talk about with your daughter that you
share an efficiency with
i think we're getting i think i think
we're getting
i think we're getting uncomfortably
close to the truth
we're getting we're getting to we're
we're now
we're now at that point right like
icarus we're flying
the comedy has us flying but we can't
get too close we're gonna keep we can't
get too close to sad
like if we the sun in this analogy would
be the sadness
and the true tragedy that that
underlying and this they found
like the tragedy and and
and just tried the tragedy that is the
foundation for all of this comedy
we don't wanna we don't wanna get to
it's like you know what i mean if you
drill too deep
you know what i mean we're gonna get to
the mantle and people are gonna die
we can't we we
we're getting dangerously close to where
i'm not
trying to pass he goes oh right the
story where
icarus flew too close to [ __ ] his
daughter
it's it's so horrible but god damn it
that's what
yeah you remember that greek myth the
guy icarus he's the one that was like
[ __ ] his daughter or whatever
no i don't remember the story being
anything like that
welcome back to twitch folks we'll see
how long
uh we last here
hey by the way if you're on twitch uh
twitch.tv
do me a favor um
[Music]
let's let's go on let me do this real
quick while um
i really think the folks at twitch
should probably have a backup
uh just in case um uh that's pretty cool
let's continue here so where where are
you from wow it's all real
let's go back to this oh yeah she's real
amanda
yeah no amanda is real yeah okay
no no amanda is real yeah
she did get a breast implant that her
dad's funded
and that's why he said she has nice
boobs yeah yeah she didn't used to have
nice foods but uh
not that she didn't used to have nice
because she used to look a lot different
yeah when we were teenagers you saw
amanda yeah
[Laughter]
she's hot she's insane she's smoking
she's smoking
gotcha she's smoking off
[Music]
i
[Music]
how
[Applause]
i'm from alaska lived there pretty much
my whole life and then now i live in
phoenix arizona so that's where i met
sammy
yeah he's the one i met at the bar right
after no i mean
no i need more now i need more
let me say something right after that
that
kevin did that thing to my eye and
everything else that happened with my
body and my hand and my eye
i met him during that time and he was
like what's wrong with your eye
yeah i helped her out i was like he was
like are you crying
because i was i was crying in public
because i didn't know what to do from
there
i did not want to go back home i didn't
feel
oh
my dad doesn't care he's so cool
yeah yeah my name's tim or people call
me baked alaska
so what is he doing guys well let me
explain
no stinger he's not pissing with the
door open why would you piss with the
door open now that would be silly
he's taking a [ __ ] folks
he's [ __ ] with the door open stinger
he's [ __ ] he just
casually in the middle of a
so where are you from fella decided to
while he saw i'm from alaska so yeah
most of my life i j
and then just just sauntered into the
bathroom and
sat on down on the toilet like it was
nothing
and he's dropping a couple kids off at
the pool
carrier monkey says he's creating an
atmosphere
[Laughter]
so there it is yes he's taking a [ __ ]
folks
because i'm from alaska by the way yes
maxi frog says that's the ultimate show
of confidence
he's asserting his dominance no long
nard says yeah no look
there's no more alpha move
prison mentality thank people points out
yeah
look there's no more alpha move in the
world
than just taking a [ __ ] right in front
of people while you're talking to him
this is like it's like a bear a bear
would do that a bear would look right at
you and take a [ __ ] no problem and what
are bears bears are [ __ ] alpha as
[ __ ] dude
yeah yeah born and raised
anchorage alaska it's really far from
here
by the way this chat was losing its
[ __ ] mind live when this was
happening
dude alaska is like the biggest place
[Laughter]
ever
i said that's not the one yeah
my dad's from california so that's like
oh you're from california it's like
right there yeah i was going to san
francisco on the coast oh nice yeah i
am i was born in san jose nice yeah i
so i went i i grew up in anchorage
he's literally wiping
and he's he's literally he's bending
over and wipe it like
this is [ __ ] this is a nightmare
somebody accurately as i said earlier
somebody last night on twitter said
it's it's it's like a rob zombie movie
this is like a rob
zombie movie